mikrochips werden heute schon in
zahlreichen bereichen des lebens
eingesetzt in die haut eingepflanzt
ersetzt
der schlüssel und kreditkarten außerdem
werden haustiere mit chips ausgestattet
und lieferungen werden verfolgt
mittlerweile also alles andere als
science fiction schon mehr als 10.000
reale personen haben die schätzungen
zufolge bereits so einen vernetzten chip
in ihrem körper was können solche
technologisch aufgerüsteten körper
bereits und wohin führt das alles
ich sage nur technologische singularität
danke für den dem vorschlag über
whatsapp und herzlich willkommen bei
klicks und science fiction
und wir euch mit mir über whatsapp und
andere messenger verknüpft das erfahrt
ihr am ende des videos wir reden hier ja
immer öfter mal wieder über die
zahlreichen möglichkeiten dem
menschlichen körper technologisch
aufzurüsten forschungsteams aus ärzten
ingenieuren und anderen wissenschaftlern
haben es schon seit längerer zeit
möglich gemacht chips zu implantieren
mit denen sich beispielsweise türen
öffnen lassen diejenigen die die chips
tragen nennen sich bio hackers iboxx
oder gründer und bei manchen von ihnen
verrät eine rot leuchtende led dass sie
solch einen chip unter ihrer haut tragen
aber es sind nicht wenige menschen die
sich zum teil selbst als
versuchskaninchen für eine revolutionäre
technologie sehen seit 2005 10
beispielsweise können sich auch die 2000
angestellten eines schwedischen startup
zentrums mit einem chip so groß wie ein
reiskorn ausstatten lassen damit sparen
sie sich schlüssel und portemonnaie der
chip öffnet ihnen die türen und auch das
mittagessen in der kantine wird darüber
abgerechnet oder der snack aus dem
automaten der lässt sich damit ganz
einfach wird zahlen außerdem lassen sich
damit auch die drucker im büro bedienen
und das interesse ist groß und so gibt
es regelmäßige partys bei denen sich die
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen den
chip einsetzen lassen diese implantate
basieren auf der near field
communication technologie kurz nfc ein
lesegerät das sich in der nähe befindet
aktiviert sie und liest informationen
aus die hier verwendeten chips verhalten
sich passiv das heißt sie speichern die
daten können aber selbst keine
informationen lesen oder sie von sich
aus ab gibt biologische medizinisch
gesehen sind sich die meisten experten
einig dass die implantate als
unbedenklich gelten diskussionswürdig
ist dagegen wieder mal das thema
überwachung und datenschutz
denn bezogen auf das büro beispiel aus
schweden das ist natürlich ein leichtes
für das unternehmen die mitarbeiter zu
überwachen wann und wo sind sie
unterwegs was ist eher so wie lange
macht sie pause und im gegensatz zu den
daten
die smartphones und beispielsweise
bankkarten sammeln werden über die
mikrochips solche informationen
permanent gesammelt man kann sie weder
ausschalten noch geht das akku
irgendwann in die knie und einmal unter
die haut gepflanzten lassen sie sich
natürlich nicht so schnell mal eben zur
seite legen solche daten zur pause
n'dour und infos zum essen sind nicht
die einzigen infos die man aus einem
körper mit einem chip erhalten könnte
die ausgereifte die chips und
größer das ethische dilemma ob
gegebenenfalls auch informationen
übermittelt werden
die eigentlich alles andere als
öffentlich sind beispielsweise wo man
sich wann aufhält mit wem man sich
trifft den partner oder die partnerin
betrübt und so weiter bislang ist dies
noch nicht so einfach möglich dafür
müsste erst einmal eine körper
freundliche energieversorgung solcher
aufwendiger chips entwickelt werden dann
könnten sich auf diesen chips die daten
ganz am mikrocomputer unterbringen
lassen leistungsfähiger prozessoren
würden dann beispielsweise auch das
online banking möglich machen oder aber
die identifikation der eigenen person so
dass staaten die chips als
identitätsfeststellung der einwohner
nutzen können doch weil diese noch
zukunftsmusik ist fehlen bislang
auch einheitliche sicherheitsstandards
dazu spätestens dann wenn man als bürger
dazu angehalten beziehungsweise in
gewisser art und weise gezwungen wird
sich chips implantieren zu lassen müsste
es bestimmte sicherheitsgarantien geben
denn stellt euch mal vor getippte
menschen als eine art usb stick auf zwei
beinen der daten austauschen kopieren
und übertragen kann
doch den eigenen körper kann man beim
besuch oder beim termin mit dem
bankberater nicht einfach zu hause
lassen wie eben ein usb stick und so
müssten zugriffsrechte geklärt werden so
dass der arzt oder die ärztin nicht an
den kontostand der patienten und
patientinnen kommt und die bankberater
eben nur an diesen nicht aber an die
gesundheitsdaten dass kunden und die
fragen gehen noch weiter möchte ich
überhaupt dass mein arzt wenn man eine
ärztin jederzeit über alle meine
lebensgewohnheiten bescheid was dass
eltern immer wissen wo ihre kinder
gerade sind und was weiß dann mein chef
oder eine chefin alles über mich was
eigentlich in den bereich privatleben
gehört nicht allzu weit entfernt ist
auch das szenario dass es gelingt
künstliche intelligenz mit auf die chips
zu bringen das würde noch ganz andere
möglichkeiten eröffnen die mikrochips
könnten als eine art frühwarnsystem
dienen dass aufgrund der
körpertemperatur dem puls oder der
müdigkeit auf eine gefahrenquelle
hinweis hier die apple watch ist ja so
ein schritt in diese richtung man kann
sie ablegen und nicht nur bei einem
selbst sondern auch bei den menschen in
unserer umgebung nicht nur das stellt
euch vor ihr steigt ins auto durchaus
weigert sich loszufahren schließlich hat
das erkannt dass er gerade so unruhig
und wütend seit dass das autofahren zu
gefährlich wäre
klingt zwar noch nach science fiction
ist aber tatsächlich in teilen schon
real in
beispielsweise zeigen fitness am ende an
ob beamte unter besonders hohem stress
stehen und apropos gesundheit wie sieht
es aus mit viren die die mikrochips in
menschlichen körpern verseuchen durch
viren angriffe von hackern
beispielsweise klar ist jedenfalls dass
jede technische entwicklung in diesem
bereich auch von cyberkriminellen genau
beobachtet wird und die persönlicher und
vertraulicher die daten sind desto
lukrativer können diese auch für
kriminelle seien das maximale szenario
wären dann sogar chips die zb vernetzt
mit dem herzschrittmacher und anderen
devices im körper und steuern oder sogar
mit dem gehirn verknüpft sind und wieso
zugriff auf künstliche intelligenz
hätten und und und und aber das wäre ja
schon die technologische singularität es
ist der nächste große schritt zu auf
einen spektakulären moment tritt diese
vorher gesagt der technologische
singularität einen wird die technik den
menschen überholen und sich
selbstständig neuer finden dann ist die
entwicklung der menschheit nicht mehr
vorhersagbar und es könnten riesige
technologische fortschritte in kürzester
zeit erreicht werden allerdings mit
solchen mikrochips im körper könnten
dann auch menschen gehackt werden eine
ganz andere form von viren keine rosige
perspektiven wenn ihr zu den ersten
gehören wollte die neues dazu erfahren
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch
auch mit mir über telegramm instagram
oder den facebook messenger verknüpften
an der vater von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
könnte direkt über mich in der redaktion
von pixum heute mit mir zum beispiel wie
dieses thema hier themen vorschlagen
einfach hier draufklicken und zu bröseln
habe ich ein kleines goodie für euch
dort im begrüßungstext versteckt und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau woche vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken der
größte kanten computer der welt von
google vorgestellt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran